may 2005 21 year old yumi huang from
south korea calls her parents
she's feeling sick probably just a
stomachache they assume but as the day
goes on her pain keeps getting worse and
worse the next day it gets so bad that
she becomes hospitalized that stomach
ache she was having turns out it wasn't
a stomachache at all it was leukemia
also known as blood cancer
over the next few months yumi would
experience all the excruciating symptoms
of the cancer she would feel tired every
day she would lose so much weight that
she becomes unrecognizable to her
friends and family but here's the thing
yumi shouldn't have gotten leukemia she
was just 21 years old most cases of the
leukemia she had mainly affected men
older than 65. she didn't smoke she
didn't have any genetic disorders so why
did a young healthy girl with her whole
life ahead of her develop such a rare
disease to understand why we need to
rewind to 2002 yumi's last year in high
school her dad a taxi driver didn't have
enough money to send her to university
but luckily she landed a job at samsung
in south korea samsung often hires what
they call obedient smart high school
students without a university degree by
working for samsung yumi hopes she can
save enough money for a future wedding
and to send her brother to university
but that never happens because just
three years into the job she suddenly
becomes deathly ill and over the next
two years yumi's death starts piecing
together what made his daughter sick
you see yumi had gotten a job at one of
samsung's semiconductor factories and in
order to make these computer chips you
have to dip a silicon wafer into a lot
of chemicals a very delicate and
fascinating process a process that
exposes workers like yumi to a lot of
harsh chemicals and the one thing that
could increase someone's chances of
getting leukemia you guessed it chemical
exposure and at 4 30 am on march 6 2007
yumi's time had finally come
yumi and her parents were on the way to
the hospital to get chemo but she
wouldn't make it she dies in the
backseat of her dad's taxi
it had become obvious to yumi's parents
and samsung why yumi died but samsung
would never admit it instead yumi's
manager visited her in the hospital
every week and offered to help with
money from the company if he could
samsung's compensation offer five checks
of around a thousand dollars each yumi's
medical bills have already piled up to
fifty thousand dollars when yumi's dad
said it wasn't enough the manager told
him that samsung one of the biggest
companies in the world didn't have any
more money to spare
it would take 11 years of fighting two
finale against one of the most powerful
conglomerates in the world before
samsung would emit any guilts
in 2018 samsung issued an apology to
yumi's family and the families of over a
hundred victims that met a similar fates
they agreed to pay out an 11.6 million
dollar compensation with each family
only getting around a hundred thousand
dollars
according to samsung killing their
workers is only worth around a hundred
thousand dollars that same year the
company ranked in 54 billion dollars in
profits
see in this world those with the most
power can get away with almost anything
power allows you to control politicians
police and even the courts this allows
you to get away with all sorts of crimes
like fraud tax evasion worker abuse and
yes even murder
and in south korea the ones with the
most power aren't the politicians but
those in charge of korea's biggest
conglomerates
[Music]
there's even a ward for powerful
families like this in korea chebos south
korea's untouchable bloodlines
and at the top of all of them is the
samsung dynasty where one out every ten
dollars made in korea is thanks to
samsung for all intents and purposes
samsung is korea as much as korea is
samsung and this gives the heirs to the
samsung dynasty unparalleled power
this is how you get away with murder
[Music]
then throw it out
[Music]
so come along
and watch
if you want a lot of power like these
korean chamber families you're gonna
need an equally powerful wallet to store
all your money in that's where ridge
wallet comes in bridge makes these super
high quality sleek rfid blocking metal
wallets and people love them the ridge
wallet already has over forty thousand
five star reviews it holds up to twelve
cards and still has room for cash and
there are over 30 unique designs to
choose from like burnt titanium and
forged carbon but personally my favorite
is the gold version that's plated in
real 18 karat gold and you'll never have
to worry about breaking your ridge
wallet because they're built from ultra
durable materials and have a lifetime
warranty plus you'll be protected from
digital pit pockets thanks to their rfid
blocking technology there is no reason
to be carrying around a big bulky wallet
anymore it looks really bad tacky
outdated and i personally just hate it
and ridge wallet offers the perfect
solution i personally love how slim
stylish and minimalist it is and rich is
sure that you'll love their wallet too
they'll even let you test it out for a
full 45 days and if you don't love it
after a month and a half you can send it
back for a full refund get 15 off your
rich wallet today by going to ridge.com
jake tran and use code jake tran that's
ridge.com slash j train with code j trim
for 15 off your ridge wallet today
thanks to rich for sponsoring this video
[Music]
it's the 60s and 70s south korea just
came out of the korean war and
businesses were in desperate need of
cash but because the people just came
out of a war they didn't have any credit
history so they couldn't get any foreign
loans no one would loan to them so the
government stepped in and borrowed money
on the people's behalf to give to local
businesses and because getting basically
free money gives you a giant advantage
over your competitors these cheap loads
help some korean family businesses
become insanely successful as time
passed some of these industries
basically turned into government
mandated monopolies entire industries
were taken over by a single business
with the government's blessing the car
industry went to hyundai electronics
went to samsung and lg telecoms oil and
media went to a company called sk and so
thanks to the korean governments the
chimbos were born and because these
giant companies made up the entire
korean economy the families who owned
these companies were directly in control
of the entire economy's success
fast forward to the day and the top 10
chapels own nearly a third of the
country's business assets the top five
biggest tables make up half of korea's
entire stock market
over the years the tables have become so
influential so powerful that they could
get away with almost whatever they
wanted
[Music]
meet heather cho the vice president and
daughter of the owner of korean error
one day she forced a plane full of
passengers to stop during takeoff
because a cabin crew member has served
her nuts in a bag instead of on a plate
she forced the crew member to apologize
on his knees and kicked him off the
plane the public was outraged as such an
arrogant abuse of power and demanded
that she be brought to justice and yet
at her sentencing she was just given one
year in jail five months later her
sentence was suspended
[Music]
this is che taiwan the chairman of sk
the second largest table in korea they
own the biggest mobile phone provider in
korea along with a ton of businesses in
energy construction telecom and more and
in 2013 this chairman was convicted of
embezzlement illegally moving company
money into his own pockets he was
sentenced to around two years in jail
but this was no ordinary prison sentence
during his time in prison he had more
than 1700 visitors he was literally
running his giant conglomerates from his
jail cell he also had his original
sentence suspended and got out long
before he was supposed to now
surprisingly after being released he was
immediately reinstated into sk
leadership the business tycoon vowed to
do his best to help bolster national
economic and social development and to
regain the public's trust
these examples are just scratching the
surface almost every year a table family
member is accused of tax evasion
embezzlement of fraud and they all get
away with it with a reduced sentence or
no jail time at all
[Music]
in 1938 samsa started out as a dried
fish trading company worth around twenty
five dollars
laid by young yangchul its founder had
no idea that years later his company
would be one of the biggest electronics
businesses in the world samsung's growth
was full of shitty deals like the
founders kids getting arrested for
smuggling 50 tons of saturn on
artificial sweetener into south korea
back in the 60s and even decades later
when things were supposed to be more
regulated the next family member in
charge of samsung changhi was convicted
of bribing ex-presidents and judges to
quote see things his way end quotes he
was pardoned after two years by the
president of south korea himself no
matter what the samsung chamber did the
company just kept growing bigger today
they have the visions in everything from
fashion hotels hospitals and security
companies the samsung smartphones alone
account for more than a fifth of korea's
exports each year and they've risen to
the second largest company in the world
this is south korean president parker j
hong hai in 2016 a massive scandal
involving her an old friend and samsung
was uncovered you see today samsung is
majority owned by foreign shareholders
and that didn't sit well with the new
head of samsung lee jae young so he came
up with a plan to bribe president park's
close friend in an attempt to get the
president to give his family more
control of the company after it was
exposed this new head of samsung was
sentenced to five years in jail
unsurprisingly his sentence was
suspended just a year later and the
president of south korea she had to
resign lee jae young is known as the
crown prince of samsung two months after
his release he was arrested and
convicted again this time on drug
charges
would you want this level of power i
kind of would welcome to the channel my
name is jake and we run one of the
biggest channels on youtube for
documentaries on money power and crime
so if you enjoyed this one we make
multiple ones of these every single week
for free so click the subscribe button
below remember you can always dislike
and unsubscribe whenever you want and if
you want longer documentaries are even
more controversial to the point where i
can't post them publicly click that join
button below and if you join and you
don't think it's worth it you can email
me and i will personally refund you the
money you can follow me on instagram at
jtrend.io watch out for fake accounts
i'm not gonna ever message you asking
you to invest in crypto or whatever
that's gonna wrap it up stay dangerous
out there and i will see you guys in the
next one
[Music]
do
[Music]
you